year in American car culture.
Ford was poised to roll
out a car that would bring
more affordable
muscle to the masses,
thanks largely to one man.
Lee Iacocca grew up in
Pennsylvania steelmaking
region, where his dad ran one of
the first car rental agencies.
As a teenager,
Iacocca was determined
to one day become an
executive at an auto company.
So after graduating from
Princeton University,
he landed his first
job at Ford in 1946.
By the time he was
only 36, Iacocca
was named vice
president at Ford,
the youngest VP In
the company's history.
Lee Iacocca understood
that Ford needed to bring
a youthful flair to its market.
NARRATOR: Millions
of baby boomers
would soon be getting
their license.
Iacocca knew that these
teenagers, who grew up
on rock and roll
and TV westerns,
would want a cool car
that was fun to drive
but still affordable.
So he directed
his team to design
a sporty coupe, priced at less
than $2,500, about $20 grand
in today's money.
To suggest speeding
through the countryside,
Iacocca named his
car, the Mustang.
[engine revving]
The Mustang was something
that was not designed just
from a transportation
standpoint,
but designed from
a fun standpoint.
NARRATOR: And like the
Pontiac GTO that year,
this lightweight car could
be fitted with a powerful V8
engine, a first for Ford.
If you even go
back through the 50s,
stuffing a big V8 into an
Impala or a Galaxie 500,
those are huge cars.
Mustang was a lot smaller,
and to put a V8 into a Mustang
meant that it inherently handled
better, got better mileage,
and was probably as good
or better performance
because it was a smaller car.
NARRATOR: Lee Iacocca
introduced Ford's latest vehicle
at the 1964 World's
Fair, which would be one
of the biggest in US history.
With 50 million visitors
from 80 nations,
this international
showcase guaranteed
the Mustang instant publicity.
ANNOUNCER: Out of
the Ford pavilion,
there's a daydream
corner called Mustang.
NARRATOR: The gambit
worked, and he and his coupe
landed on the front of
both "Time" and "Newsweek,"
the first time either
publication featured
a retail product on its cover.
The Mustang exploded
in terms of sales.
Lee Iacocca was so
dead on understanding
what people wanted.
It sold incredibly well.
Ford planned on producing 80,000
Mustangs in its first year,
but within a year and a half,
they'd sold over a million,
breaking all post-World
War II auto sales records.
The customer base was all over
the place, from women, to men,
to young, to old.
It just had this kind
of universal appeal
that I don't think Detroit
had ever seen before.
NARRATOR: The magnitude of
the Mustang's popularity
put the other car
makers on notice.
When Ford came out with
the Mustang, everybody
was caught flat-footed.
And so for three
years, the Mustang
ran absolutely unchecked.
NARRATOR: By 1968,
both Ford and Chrysler
offered muscle cars
with oversized engines
well over 400 cubic inches.
The younger market
loved these fast rides,
and that gave manufacturers
the green light they needed
to storm back to the track.
The muscle car era
was in full force.